A LOT MORE COMING UP IN A
SECOND.
A LOT OF DEVELOPMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
FIRST TONIGHT THE DEMOCRATS'
CRAZY TRAIN HAS YET ANOTHER
PASSENGER BECAUSE THERE HE
IS CRAZY UNCLE JOE BIDEN
AFTER DELAYING HIS LAUNCH
AND DELAYING IT AGAIN.
HE IS FINALLY NOW JUMPED
INTO THE 2020 RACE.
HE IS NOW THE 20TH DEMOCRAT
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
THAT'S A RECORD.
NOW, WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
NEXT IS GOING TO BE PRETTY
REMARKABLE AS JOE BIDEN
TRIES TO COURT THE NEW ULTRA
RADICAL EXTREME SOCIALIST
LEFT DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
CONVINCE THEM, WELL, HE'S
THEIR GUY.
BUT EVEN THE BIGGER STORY IS
OVERSEAS.
AND THAT'S SURROUNDING JOE
BIDEN'S SHADY INVOLVEMENT
WITH UKRAINE BREAKING
TONIGHT ALSO.
YOU REMEMBER JOHN SOLOMON
EXPLAINED ON THIS PROGRAM
WHILE JOE BIDEN WAS VICE
PRESIDENT HIS SON HUNTER
TOOK A LUCRATIVE JOB AT A
MAJOR CREW RAINYIAN ENERGY
COMPANY AND BY THE WAY IS
ALSO PETER SCHWEIZER ON THE
CHINA DEAL BUT WHEN THE
COMPANY BECAME THE SUBJECT
OF A CORRUPTION PROBE IN THE
COUNTRY, BIDEN USED HIS
INFLUENCE AND YOUR MONEY TO
LITERALLY GET THE LEAD
PROSECUTOR FIRED.
WE WILL PLAY THE TAPE AS
SOLOMON REPORTS THE
PROSECUTOR WAS ACTUALLY
INVESTIGATING BIDEN'S SON.
AND BIDEN USED THE THREAT OF
PULLING U.S. STATE AID
DOLLARS, YOUR TAX DOLLARS IF
THEY DIDN'T FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR.
THIS IS A HUGE DEVELOPING
STORY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AND REMIND
YOU OF WHAT HE HAD SAID.
>> WE'RE NOT GOING TO GIVE
YOU THE BILLION DOLLARS.
THEY SAID YOU HAVE NO
AUTHORITY.
YOU ARE NOT THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT SAID I SAID
CALL HIM.
[LAUGHTER]
I'M TELL YOU ARE NOT GETTING
A BILLION DOLLARS.
I SAID YOU ARE NOT GETTING A
BILLION.
I WILL BE LEAVING HERE AND I
THINK IT WAS WHAT, 6 HOURS.
LEAVING IN SIX HOURS.
THE PROSECUTOR IS NOT FIRED,
YOU ARE NOT GETTING THE
MONEY.
WELL SON OF [BLEEP] GOT
FIRED U.
>> Sean: SIX HOURS.
AMERICAN MONEY.
SAME GUY?
REALLY?
OKAY.
INVESTIGATING YOUR SON?
NOW WE HAVE BEEN REPORTING
ON UKRAINE, ATTEMPTING AND
ADMITTING THEY TRIED TO
INFLUENCE THE 2016 ELECTION.
THEY ARE OFFERING THIS
COUNTRY THE EVIDENCE ON
BEHALF OF HILLARY.
THE QUESTION NOW IS WHERE
ARE ALL THE PEOPLE SO
WORRIED ABOUT COLLUSION?
TONIGHT THE STORY
SURROUNDING UKRAINE GETS
EVEN MURKIER BECAUSE JOHN JOHN
SOLOMON BREAKING NEWS RIGHT
NOW NEW BOMBSHELL PIECE THAT
DETAILS HOW THE OBAMA WHITE
HOUSE WORKED WITH UKRAINE TO
GIVE THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
NARRATIVE AN EARLY BOOST.
JOINING US NOW TO EXPLAIN IS
THE HILL'S JOHN SOLOMON.
JOHN, THIS IS HUGE.
>> YEAH, IT IS. FIRST
INSTANCE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE
VERY EARLY AS DONALD TRUMP
IS RISING EARLY GETTING
INVOLVED.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE THE NATIONAL
SECURITY COUNCIL SILL
INVITED ALL UKRAINE
AUTHORITIES, THE
PROSECUTORS, ANTICORRUPTION
INVESTIGATORS, HELD A
MEETING IN JANUARY 2016,
JUST BEFORE THE BEGINNING.
PRIMARIES AND SAID, LISTEN,
WE WOULD LIKE TO FIND SOME
NEW WAY TO REINVOG RATE AN
OLD CASE THE PARTY OF
REASONS CASE.
THE CASE WHERE THERE WAS
MONEY BEING PAID TO LOB LOBBYISS
PAUL MANAFORT AND GREG
CRAIG.
COULD YOU HELP US GET
RESTARTED.
SET IN MOTION MAD SCRAMBLE
IN UKRAINE.
ULTIMATELY RESULTS IN THE
DISCOVERY OF A LEDGER GETS
LEAKED WITH ONLY PAUL
MANAFORT AND LEFT GREG CRAIG
OUT AND THAT STARTS THE
WHOLE RUSSIAN COLLUSION
CASE.
WHAT YOU HAVE IS THE
BEGINNING OF THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION NARRATIVE STARTING
THIS THE OBAMA WHITE HOUSE.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
JOHN, I THOUGHT WE WERE
GOING BACK TO -- LET ME ASK
YOU THIS.
WE SHOWED THE FIRST TAPE OF
JOE BIDEN.
HOW CERTAIN ARE WE THAT THEY
HAVE EVIDENCE OF THIS
PROSECUTOR THAT HE WAS
TELLING ON TAPE, BRAGGING
ABOUT HAVING GOTTEN FIRED
USING AMERICAN MONEY.
HOW CERTAIN ARE WE THAT THAT
PROSECUTOR WAS INVESTIGATING
HIS SON AT THE TIME?
>> OH, IT'S IRREFUTABLE.
I HAVE IN MY POSSESSION
DOCUMENTS FROM THE UKRAINE'S
GENERAL PROSECUTOR'S OFFICE
THAT STATES ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS AND ONE OF THE
PEOPLE THEY WANTED TO
INTERVIEW WAS HUNTER BIDEN
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
$3 MILLION.
NOW, THAT'S THE FIGURE THE
UKRAINIANS CAME UP WITH
SEPARATELY.
THE FBI CAME UP WITH THEIR
OWN BANK TRANSACTIONS IN NEW
YORK GOING INTO A COMPANY
CONTROLLED BY HUNTER BIDEN
THE SAME AMOUNT OF MONEY
$3 MILLION OUT OF UKRAINE
FROM THAT ENERGY COMPANY
INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THE FBI AND UKRAINE FROM THE
SAME EVIDENCE.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT WAS
THAT MONEY FOR AND WAS IT IN
ANY WAY IMPROPER?
THAT'S WHAT NEEDS TO BE
INVESTIGATED AND UKRAINIAN
AUTHORITIES WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE THAT EVIDENCE AS JOE
BIDEN NOW BEGINS RUNNING FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
>> Sean: PRETTY AMAZING.
JOHN SOLOMON, THANK YOU FOR
THAT REPORT.
WE WILL ASK THE PRESIDENT
FOR HIS REACTION IN A FEW
MINUTES.
NOW, BEYOND BIDEN'S SHADY
INTERNATIONAL DEALINGS, HE
FACES AN UPHILL CLIMB AND
ALREADY DOING EVERYTHING HE
CAN DO TO TRY AND COZY UP TO
THE FAR LEFT OF HIS PARTY.
LOOK AT HIS ROLLOUT VIDEO.
>> I BELIEVE HISTORY WILL
LOOK BACK ON FOUR YEARS OF
THIS PRESIDENT AND ALL HE
EMBRACES AS AN ABERRANT
MOMENT IN TIME IF WE GIVE
DONALD TRUMP EIGHT YEARS IN
THE WHITE HOUSE HE WILL
FOREVER AND FUNDAMENTALLY
ALTER THE CHARACTER OF THIS
NATION, WHO WE ARE AND I CAN
NOT STAND BY AND WATCH THAT
HAPPEN.
>> Sean: HERE WE ARE?
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN-AMERICANS, HISPANIC
AMERICANS, ASIAN AMERICANS,
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE AND
OH AND YOUTH UNEMPLOYMENT.
WE HAVE LITERALLY WAGE
GROWTH, STAGNANT FOR 10
YEARS, REALLY?
NOW IT'S BACK BETTER
STRONGER THAN EVER.
THAT'S HATEFUL?
THAT'S BAD FOR AMERICA?
I DON'T THINK THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THINK SO.
DESPITE BIDEN'S ATTEMPTS TO
APPEASE THIS FAR LEFT
RADICAL SOCIALIST BASE OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, WELL,
THEY ARE ALREADY SOUNDING
THE ALARM AGAINST HIM.
NOW IN A NEW TWEET FROM THE
GROUP JUSTICE DEMOCRATS, THE
SAME GROUP BEHIND THE RISE
OF CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, OHIO CALL
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI ONLY IN
NAME ONLY.
WELL THE GROUP WROTE QUOTE
BIDEN IS OUT OF TOUCH WITH
THE CENTERED OF ENERGY IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TODAY.
AND DON'T FORGET CONGRESSMAN
OCASIO-CORTEZ ALREADY WENT
FIRMLY ON THE RECORD.
SHE DOES NOT WANT BIDEN TO
BE THE NOMINEE.
AND WE WILL REMIND YOU.
>> THIS IDEA THAT WE CAN GO
BACK TO THE GOOD OLD DAYS
WITH OBAMA, WITH OBAMA'S
VICE PRESIDENT I THINK, YOU
KNOW, THERE IS AN EMOTIONAL
ELEMENT TO THAT.
BUT I DON'T WANT TO GO BACK.
I WANT TO GO FORWARD.
>> LOOK AT THIS ARTICLE FROM
THE LIBERAL WEBSITE SLATE
COMPARING BIDEN TO JEB BUSH
CALLING HIM A WEAK
ESTABLISHMENT CANDIDATE.
THE HEADLINE IN THE A.P.
READS, QUOTE:  SOME WOMEN OF
COLOR FRUSTRATED BYE BYE
DEN'S PRESIDENTIAL BID
RAISING EVEN MORE QUESTIONS
ABOUT HIS CAMPAIGN'S APPEAL
BASED ON PAST STATEMENTS ON
INTEGRATION AND BUSING AND,
GET THIS, IT LOOKS LIKE
BIDEN MAY NOT EVEN HAVE THE
BACKING OF HIS OLD BOSS
BARACK OBAMA.
AND THE BEST PART IS HOW
UNCLE JOE IS TRYING TO SPIN
THIS WELL, UNCOMFORTABLE
TRUTH.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHY DIDN'T PRESIDENT
OBAMA ENDORSE YOU?
>> I ASKED PRESIDENT OBAMA
NOT TO ENDORSE AND HE
DOESN'T WANT TO -- WE
SHOULD -- WHOEVER WINS THIS
NOMINATION SHOULD WIN IT ON
THEIR OWN MERITS.
>> Sean: GREAT QUESTION,
PETER.
DOES ANYONE ACTUALLY BELIEVE
THAT?
THAT BARACK OBAMA WAS ALL
SET TO ENDORSE HIM AND THEN
JOE STOPPED HIM?
WELL, LET NOT YOUR HEART BE
TROUBLED, JOE, BOWERS THE
BIG COVETED ENDORSEMENT IS
ALREADY ROLLING IN LIKE FROM
CONSPIRACY TV DARLING
DISGRACED ATTORNEY MICHAEL
AVENATTI TWEETED THIS ABOUT
BIDEN HE OFFERS DEMS THE
VERY BEST CHANCE IN 2020
ESPECIALLY IN KEY STATES.
HE HAS THE FIGHT,
INTELLIGENCE, FORTITUDE TO
BEAT TRUMP AND BEGIN TO MAKE
AMERICA, AMERICA AGAIN.
HE HAS MY ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT.
OH, AND BIDEN BRAGGING
SAYING ALL THESE FOREIGN
LEADERS ARE BEGGING ME TO
SAVE THE COUNTRY AND THE
WORLD.
REALLY?
GETTING A LITTLE MESSIAH
COMPLEX?
ANYWAY, REMEMBER, BIDEN
ENTERS THE RACE ALREADY
TRYING TO FEND OFF SCANDAL
AFTER SCANDAL.
MULTIPLE WOMEN HAVE ACCUSED
HIM OF INAPPROPRIATE
TOUCHING, KISSING, TOUCHING,
ACTUAL VIDEO FOOTAGE OF
BIDEN'S DISTURBING TOUCHING
ANTICS.
DOESN'T THIS ALONE
IMMEDIATELY DISQUALIFY IN
THE ICE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY?
AND BIDEN WAS A REPUBLICAN,
WHAT WOULD THEY BE SAYING IN
THE DOUBLE STANDARD IS ON
FULL DISPLAY.
NOW OUR FRIENDS OVER AT
CAMPUS REFORM DECIDED TO ASK
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHAT THEY
THINK OF HIS BEHAVIOR.
THIS IS INTERESTING.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHAT'S YOUR REACTION WHEN
YOU SEE THESE VIDEOS.
>> CREEPY,.
>> EWE.
>> STRANGE SIDE THEY HAVE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT CLIPS WHICH
OBVIOUSLY DOESN'T LOOK VERY
GOOD FOR JOE BIDEN.
>> DEFINITELY CREEPY.
VARIOUS AGES OF WOMEN, TOO.
IT'S NOT JUST YOUNG WOMEN
AND A LITTLE BIT OLDER
WOMEN.
SO IT'S JUST VERY WRONG AND
THAT SHOULD NOT BE A THING.
>> YEAH.
I THINK IT'S A CLASSIC
EXAMPLE OF MEN NOT
RESPONDING TO BEING AROUND
WOMEN PROPERLY.
>> Sean: THERE IS A REPORT
TONIGHT IN THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" THAT HE CALLED ANITA
HILL.
SHE WAS NOT PARTICULARLY
IMPRESSED THAT HE
UNDERSTANDS HIS POSITION
BACK DURING THE CLARENCE
THOMAS HEARING.
THAT TROUBLE THERE.
NOW, DESPITE ALL THESE EARLY
TROUBLES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID OFFER A
LONG WARM WELCOME TO FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN
TWEETING:  QUOTE:  WELCOME
TO THE RACE SLEEPY JOE.
IT WILL BE NASTY.
YOU WILL BE CEILING WITH
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SICK AND
DEMENTED IDEAS.
BUT IF YOU MAKE IT, I WILL
SEE YOU AT THE STARTING
GATE.
I WONDER IF THE MEDIA WILL
ASK CRAZY UNCLE JOE ABOUT
SOME OF THESE FINALLER
MOMENTS HE HAS HAD OVER THE
YEARS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU CANNOT GO TO A 7/11
OR A DUNKIN' DONUT UNLESS
YOU HAVE A SLIGHT INDIAN
ACCENT.
I'M NOT JOKING.
>> WHAT KIND OF A CHANCE
WOULD A NORTHEASTERN LIBERAL
JOE BIDEN HAVE IN THE
CHANCE?
>> BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
YOU DON'T KNOW MY STATE.
MY STATE WAS A SLAVE STATE.
MY STATE IS A BORDER STATE.
MY STATE IS THE EIGHTH
LARGEST BLACK POPULATION IN
THE COUNTRY.
>> GOT THE FIRST SORT OF
MAINSTREAM AFRICAN-AMERICAN
ARE A ARTICULATE AND CLEAN
AND NICE-LOOKING GUY.
I MEAN THAT'S A STORY BOOK.
>> ROMNEY WANTS TO LET -- HE
SAID IN THE FIRST 100 DAYS
HE IS GOING TO LET THE BIG
BANKS ONCE AGAIN WRITE THEIR
OWN RULES.
UNCHAIN WALL STREET.
THEY ARE GOING TO PUT Y'ALL
BACK IN CHAINS.
>> Sean: OF COURSE NOW ANITA
HILL IS NOT A FAN AND
TOUCHING IN HIS GAFFES AND
HIS CREEPY BEHAVIOR MAYBE IN
THE SPOTLIGHT BUT HE HAS
EVEN BIGGER SCANDAL BREWING.
REMEMBER, BIDEN HAS TO RUN
ON OBAMA'S ECONOMIC
FAILURES.
THAT WAS BY KENNEL-OBAMA.
THEIR FOREIGN POLICY
BLUNDERS LIKED RIDICULOUS
IRAN DEAL.
AND YOU CAN EXPECT ANOTHER
APOLOGY TOUR FOR AMERICA.
WHO WOULD EVER DROP
$150 BILLION IN CASH AND
OTHER CURRENCY ON THE TARMAC
RADICAL ISLAMIC MULLAHS WHO
CHANT DEATH TO AMERICA AND
THREATEN TO ANNIHILATE
AMERICA AND ISRAEL?
WHY WOULD ANYBODY EVER DO
THAT?
YOU WANT TO GO BACK TO THAT?
AND EVEN BIGGER THAN THAT
ARE THE QUESTIONS
SURROUNDING OBAMA'S WHITE
HOUSE'S ROLE IN THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER, CORRUPTION
SCANDAL IN OUR NATION'S
HISTORY.
REMEMBER THE 2016 RUSSIAN
METTLINGING THAT ALL
HAPPENED ON BIDEN AND
OBAMA'S WATCH.
THAT MEANS, YEAH, THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE.
THE DIRTY DOSSIER, THE
RIGGED INVESTIGATION INTO
HILLARY, THE FISA ABUSE.
THE USE OF AN INFORMANT TO
SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
YEAH, IT'S ALL CREEPING
CLOSER AND CLOSER TO THE
OBAMA WHITE HOUSE.
HOW HIGH UP DID IT GO?
HOW DID THIS ALL START?
WHAT DID THEY KNOW?
WHEN DID THEY KNOW IT?
HILLARY CLINTON CONTINUES TO
FUEL HER COLLUSION FANTASY
SAYING SHE WAS THE VICTIM
OF, QUOTE, A RUSSIAN PLOT.
WOW.
LIKE WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
YOU AN AVALANCHE OF TRUTH IS
COMING CASCADING DOWN IT
WILL EXPOSE THE DEEP STATE.